[Music]
on this saturday night horrific hate
crime caught on camera
we are seeing unprovoked assaults
continue to happen in the city the
latest in a disturbing wave of random
attacks in vancouver and the plea for
help from police
plus no relief for pocketbook pain
restoring price stability will take some
time consumers continue to take the hit
on inflation interest rates and even
tips
a tall glass of tap water it's
definitely a whole new world for us the
decades-long journey for a bc first
nation to get clean drinking water
and inspiring muslim athletes
a stanley cup champion brings hockey's
greatest trophy to a hometown mosque to
bring this big shiny trophy back to my
hometown it's really come full circle
[Music]
global national with bara nasser
reporting tonight tracy tong
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin tonight in vancouver where
police are alerting the public about
another unprovoked assault this one took
place during the city's pride weekend
and is being investigated as a hate
crime
attacks on strangers appear to be on the
rise in the west coast city with more
than 10 a month reported to police since
march and residents are on edge
catherine urkhart reports
surveillance video captures a vicious
unprovoked stranger attack outside an
east vancouver convenience store a drink
is thrown on the 42 year old victim who
is then repeatedly punched and kicked by
three young men
two women watch police say the victim
had just bought a slurpee after
celebrating pride week it's just the
latest unprovoked attack in vancouver
this year
and we do believe that it was motivated
by hate
this happened during pride week and
i understand that the suspects did utter
some homophobic threats to the victim
during the attack last week police
arrested a 21-year-old man after a
54-year-old woman was viciously attacked
inside her home
investigators then linked the suspect to
three stranger assaults one involved a
woman being stabbed i think it's really
scary i mean i've lived here
most of my life and felt quite safe even
you know in my in my twenties living on
my own and now i'm kind of freaked out
to go at night between march and june
alone police have dealt with 44 stranger
assaults generally speaking i can tell
you that
in these cases that we're seeing in
vancouver repeated serial random violent
unprovoked attacks mental health is a
huge factor earlier this summer another
random assault made headlines on the
downtown east side a man armed with a
machete attacked four people in his
rooming house leaving them with
life-altering injuries
now as police investigate the latest
unprovoked attack and hate crime a plea
for help we need people that stopped and
watched to also come forward so we can
get a full picture of what happened that
plea coming as the public's frustration
and fear mounts
with every assault
catheter cart global news
vancouver
the quebec government has announced
plans to invest 250 million dollars over
five years to hire more police officers
in montreal and combat gun violence
across the province
we sense that with the events that
occurred this week and in the previous
weeks we needed to have an exceptional
and important gesture and investments to
make sure that we have more police
officers on the streets
montrealers want to see more police
officers on the streets
the announcement comes after quebec
premier francois lego vowed to restore
order and protect citizens following a
spate of shootings in recent months
including two daylight shootings on
tuesday in montreal
45 million is earmarked to bolster the
presence of police in the city 200
million is set to strengthen a
province-wide crackdown on the gun trade
well last month the annual inflation
rate dropped to 7.6 percent taking some
of the heat off canadian household
budgets but south of the border
americans are still looking for a break
and it likely won't happen anytime soon
in an eye-opening speech the chairman of
the u.s federal reserve warned consumers
will experience more pain before things
get better jennifer johnson explains
with prices skyrocketing on just about
every consumer good from groceries to
gas americans are desperate for relief
but it won't come anytime soon the
federal reserve chair is warning there
will likely be more interest rate hikes
next month to try and stabilize the
economy restoring price stability will
take some time and requires using our
tools forcefully
to bring demand and supply into better
balance they will also bring some pain
to households and businesses
with that news wall street immediately
tanked small business owners are feeling
the pain too even places like ice cream
shops because dairy prices are higher
than ever we have to pass that on to the
consumer we can't absorb all that you
know as a company and be able to stay
afloat the federal reserve has already
raised interest rates twice since june
financial experts say now is the time to
try and pay down what you owe you really
want to try to whittle down your credit
card debt as much as possible because
those rates are going to continue to go
up mortgage rates continue to rise too
home sales have dropped for six straight
months as potential buyers do the math
and realize they can no longer afford to
buy what they want you know that
honeymoon ended and it's a different
market today president joe biden
continues to downplay concerns and
dismissing critics who say his new
student loan forgiveness program will
further drive up inflation the president
is promising just the opposite will
happen we got people who are in fact now
going to be freed up to be able to go
borrow money to buy a home to be able to
start businesses to do the things that
need to be done as inflation remains at
its highest level in four decades
consumer spending has stalled it barely
rose in july
buyers are holding on to their money
until prices finally start to fall again
jennifer johnson global news washington
well as inflation continues its upward
trend canadians have noticed another
part of their everyday life getting more
expensive a phenomenon known as tip
creep or tip inflation has become common
across the country from takeout to hair
salons and restaurants the expected
gratuity amount has gone up and some
experts say it's here to stay and
gaviola explains
tip-flation means you're being asked for
gratuity in places you've never been
asked before and the amount is higher
than it used to be a lot of people
are already upset with the fact that the
cost of living is so high they go to the
grocery store they pay more they go to
the gas station they pay more and now
they're picking up something that
normally they just threw a dollar fifty
on the table for and they're being asked
to tip for it according to restaurants
canada 44 percent said they were tipping
more when dining out than pre-pandemic
women more likely than men to be ponying
up extra for gratuities those aged 55
and up most likely to be more generous
and people in ontario and bc lead the
country in increased tipping because the
hospitality industry was
disproportionately hammered during the
pandemic with many workers livelihoods
disrupted there's a new appreciation for
service workers these days you know 15
is the bare minimum 15 to 20 is normal
and over 20 or even 30 is what you would
give for exceptional service some of
this is due to technology with an
increasing number of payments going
digital merchants can add a tip prompt
and many are doing so for the first time
this can be a percentage of the total
amount including tax which can boost the
gratuity
personal finance expert barry choi says
tipping should be in line with the
service you're getting your hair stylist
may get more than a barista for example
if you're only just coming in grabbing
your food and leaving and there's no
service involved i don't think you
should feel ashamed or embarrassed if
you're not going to leave a tip in that
scenario but if tipping extra for
service in a restaurant is a financial
stretch for you he suggests cutting back
on the number of times you dine out
rather than on the amount that you're
tipping it's way easier for you
to make changes to your budget to reduce
your spending than someone who might be
working a minimum wage job where they
are depending solely on that income just
for the bare necessities some say
employers shouldn't pass the buck for
living wages onto consumers already
dealing with inflation at multi-decade
highs
anne gaviola global news toronto
well with the return to school coming
soon some parents are calling for the
expansion of booster eligibility for
their kids health canada approved the
shot for children aged 5 to 11 last week
but many parents are still struggling to
find a third dose for their kids ahead
of the fall
as shalima maharaja explains that's
pushed some to cross the border in
search of the vaccine
we really wanted to have the protection
from a third dose before school starts
especially because we're at a point in
the pandemic where
you know i think a lot of other
protection measures aren't going to be
in place this year so the mother of two
took her son south of the border to get
the shots he's currently ineligible to
receive in ontario i have seen a few
people really through twitter who had
mentioned to me that this is an option
going to ogdensburg to get the vaccine
we didn't we didn't really want to do
that we assumed that it would eventually
be open in ontario so we kind of waited
and waited and waited gibbs who ran for
the ontario liberals in june's
provincial election posted this photo to
twitter calling out the government for a
delayed rollout of third doses global
news reached out to the ministry of
health requesting an interview with the
minister and received this response we
are reviewing nasty's most recent
guidance and will be providing details
for booster shots for this age group in
the coming days
last week health canada gave pfizer's
booster the stamp of approval to be used
on kids 5 to 11. on wednesday manitoba
expanded its eligibility criteria for
the third dose to include that age group
by protecting them we are also
protecting families epidemiologist nazim
muhajarin supports the expansion of
third dose eligibility criteria just as
we don't question about
putting a seat belt on when we get into
a car i don't think that we should be
really second-guessing you know whether
we need a vaccine at this point in time
it is our insurance policy against any
threat to our well-being as for katie
gibbs our kids are still
in daycare and going to school
but we want to
take any extra levels of protection that
we can shalima maharaj global news
the federal government is warning
canadians to be cautious while visiting
pakistan as that country deals with
deadly flooding
pakistani officials say nearly 1 000
people have been killed and thousands
more have been injured or displaced
since the monsoon season began in
mid-june
the crisis has forced the government to
declare a state of emergency and to ask
for international help to deal with the
damage
monsoon rains are expected to continue
in the coming days
and coming up breaking down barriers for
a new generation of diverse scientists
plus the lasting legacy of the stanley
cup's visit to an ontario mosque stay
with us
a group of student scientists in halifax
are working to get the next generation
of black and indigenous youth interested
in ecology through workshops and fair
compensation they hope to turn the tides
on a field that is predominantly white
and full of barriers for many people of
color hoping to break into the
discipline
ashley field reports
these brothers are getting their hands
dirty learning all about an animal
they've been fascinated with for as long
as they can remember i dissected a shark
i
basically saw its liver and its stomach
it was really fun because it's my first
time opening one so this is a spiny
dogfish it's a hands-on experience made
possible through diversity of nature an
outreach organization for bipark youth
as scientists in this position of
privilege one of the best things we
could do to help elevate racialized
members of the community was to share
science with them the group facilitates
workshops and programming led by bypoc
science students to help break down
barriers and provide role models for
racialized youth interested in the field
often in science we tend to see
one type of person reflected as a
scientist what we want to show these
kids is that anyone can be a scientist
even people who look like them people of
color within that north american
contingent there's very few there's
several
sizable barriers that exist for people
to get in the field a lack of
representation a big one he says but so
too is the field's reliance on unpaid
work there's a lot of people that could
potentially be interested in the field
but they don't have the resources to
make that entry step back in 2020 he and
more than 700 other marine mammal
researchers signed a petition taking a
stand against unpaid positions a barrier
they say unfairly targets those who
don't have the resources as many of my
friends from wealthier backgrounds were
able to volunteer their time in labs i
was life guarding and this is a story
that i've heard from many racialized
scholars and scholars from low income
communities massey now hoping to be a
part of the change ensuring all
educators here like undergraduate
student aaron judah are fairly
compensated a lot of us have had
different experiences whether it's not
being fully you know trusted with stuff
or being underestimated but now we have
amazing leaders around the world from
these communities really showing just
how powerhouse diverse scientists can be
remember to always push it away from you
providing opportunities for both current
students and potential future ones
ashley field global news halifax
ahead an emotional drink the long road a
bc first nations community took to
finally tap in to a clean water supply
well after decades of waiting some
residents of the cowichan tribes the
largest single first nation band in
british columbia finally have clean
drinking water
members of the first nation on vancouver
island have been living there since the
1940s but as kylie stanton reports the
community has never had potable water
despite being just two kilometers from
the nearest city
as water pours from this tap it's almost
hard to believe have a drink baby for
residents living on 20 properties along
indian road in cowichan tribes this is a
first it's been
a long time coming that's for sure yeah
it was unbelievable for me i got pretty
choked up about it it's just like wow i
can't believe it we're here
we can drink water from our own tap baba
koshimit has relied on either well or
bottled water his entire life more than
three decades of it spent in cowichan
raising his family what he says had its
challenges you couldn't even consider
drinking it was fizzing like pop when it
came out of the top want another drink
his daughter has since been raising her
children under the same conditions the
water only suitable for laundry and
bathing on good days having to use
bottled water for everything from
cooking dinner to
like bathing our babies to you know
making a jug of juice had to come out of
a bottle it's definitely a whole new
world for us
something so simple so many of us take
for granted is something to celebrate
here
[Applause]
the community marking the milestone with
a ribbon-cutting ceremony on friday you
know when we think about
water that's not safe for our community
to drink we think of this happening in
rural communities but really it's here
in we're you know the biggest nation
here in bc and we don't have clean
drinking water for our people the homes
are located here neighboring the city of
duncan just two kilometers away but it's
taken decades of work to finally land
the necessary federal funding to make
clean drinking water a reality i think
that it's really good for people to be
aware of and not take advantage of
things that they do have the luxuries
that they do have
there is still work to be done roughly
another 20 homes have yet to secure
access and there's currently no timeline
as to when that's expected to happen my
heart goes out to those that are still
having to live that way because i know
what that was like so still there are no
grudges here
only gratitude forever grateful kylie
stanton global news
next conquering the rubik's cube how
these calgary siblings are taking their
skills to a global stage
[Applause]
nasam
brought hockey's biggest prize back to
his hometown of london ontario today
celebrating with family friends and
close-knit fans qadri is believed to be
the first muslim player to become a
stanley cup champion now before kicking
off a parade he took the cup to the
london muslim mosque which is minutes
away from where four members of the
ufsell family were killed and another
boy was injured in a hate crime in june
last year and is the same mosque the
family attended
you know these are the streets i used to
run around as a kid
and uh you know to be to bring this big
shiny trophy back to my hometown it's
really come full circle
and i just thank you guys for being here
with me
[Applause]
it is believed to be the first time the
stanley cup has ever been inside a
mosque in its
124 year history
cadre who began his career with toronto
has signed with the calgary flames after
winning the cup with the colorado
avalanche
he says he wants the moment to act as
inspiration and motivation for the next
generation of canadians
now to the canadian siblings who have
managed to conquer one of the world's
best known puzzles eric ismail who is
nine can solve the rubik's cube in just
12 seconds his sister zora born with one
hand can do it in about a minute and a
half
our jamie dahl spoke with the calgary
kids who first picked up the cube during
the pandemic and to their father a
doctor treating alzheimer's about the
cube's benefits beyond the fun
seven years old in the middle of a
pandemic eric ismail picked up his first
rubik's cube he borrowed one from oh
from the neighbor he borrowed one from a
neighbor
it was two-sided i learned how to solve
that
easy-peasy
it was really stiff and hard but it just
reminded me of
you know over 30 years ago when i did a
little bit of cubing
my dad told me that when he was little
he could solve the big ones like these
with three
before long he was faster than me and
then twice as fast and then three times
as fast and then you were left in the
dust
in the dust now nine he's been to two
competitions one in sweden and one in
edmonton he studies videos and
researches algorithms constantly trying
to get faster my record is
12.94 so that's 12 seconds
everywhere he goes he brings a cube
i always i'm always like i can solve it
too
eric's sister zora can solve it in under
a minute and a half
born with just one hand but she doesn't
let that get in her way of anything i
ride horses and i do gymnastics i'm a
normal human i can do
what everyone else can do if not better
i don't usually say this but
i in my mind i think that's actually
really cool how she can solve it with
one hand now she's striving to catch up
to her little brother's cube record
definitely to be faster when they have
their cubes and it draws a bit of a
crowd they feel proud of themselves and
each other
it's more than just a fun hobby when
he's not cubing with his kids dr zane
ismail is an alzheimer specialist
frankly the best prevention starts
at this age when you build cognitive
reserve and brain reserve
with cubing with cubing with you know
enriched activities with sports with
bilingualism eric now has his sights set
on making it to the finals in
competition and the siblings are already
teaching their youngest brother how to
solve puzzles
jamie daw global news
wow that is so impressive and that is
global national for this saturday night
i'm tracy tong tonight's your canada is
this field of sunflowers in dougald
manitoba we love seeing your canada so
please keep emailing your photos to
viewers at globalnational.com
thanks for watching see you again
tomorrow have a great night
[Music]